dans l'église orthodoxe nous suivons le
calendrier julien le canari dit julien
donc de jules césar
l'église catholique suit le calendrier
grégorien donc à quoi avec les années
bissextiles
il ya une différence par moments d'une
quinzaine de jours donc c'est à tous les
quatre ans nous fêtons pâques à la même
année à la même date que des catholiques
romains ensuite ce sera une semaine deux
semaines ça va jusqu'à un mois de
différence puisque nous fêtons pâques
notre cadre essuie déjà les cycles
lunaires et nous fêtons pas qu à peu
près juste après la pâque juive ou
presque en même temps que la pâque juive
puisque nous le savons bien dans les
textes jésus est entré dans jérusalem
lors de la pâque juive
donc on veut pas fêter pâques avant les
juifs au total il ya plus près 52 jours
de carême il y à la préparation au
carême la première la première semaine
des viandes ou nous allons cesser de
manger de la viande ensuite la semaine
des laitages ou nous cessons de manger
tout ce qu'elle est à jeun beurre lait
fromages etc et le également j'oubliais
les yeux et ensuite nous rentrons
pleinement dans les 40 jours de carême
qui se termine par le début de la
semaine sainte
semaine sainte qui évidemment qui
conclut par le dimanche de pâques le
dimanche la finale
donc nous avons eu les offices seul
pendant le prenons plutôt pendant le
carême il ya des offices le mercredi
soir et le vendredi soir ce qu'on
appelle la liturgie les pressentis fier
ou le pain était consacrée le dimanche
si on ne peut plus consacré en semaine
et nous les consommons le sable mais
reconnaissons le vendredi soir lors de
l'office liturgique et l'âme le jeûne
est beaucoup plus complet beaucoup plus
strictes durant la semaine sainte
puisque nous avons les trois premiers
jours de l'été j'ai pressenti fier
consacré le dimanche précédent ensuite
nous entrons dans le mercredi saint
jeudi saint vendredi c'est la mise au
tombeau du christ à vers 15h le
samedi c'est également nous faisons les
vêpres le soir celui de la ligue d'une
liturgie et nos conclusions
le dimanche matin par le dimanche pascal
la liturgie pascal nous proclamons que
le christ est ressuscité dans toutes les
langues